so many of us who care about sustainable
development and livelihood of local
people do suffer deeply personal reasons
I grew up in Cameroon a contravene
chanting beauty rich biodiversity but
plagued by poor governance environmental
destruction and poverty as a child like
we see we moisture in sub-sahara Africa
today I really refer to malaria to this
day more than 1 million people die from
malaria every year
mostly children under the age of 5 with
90 percent according in sub-saharan
Africa almost 18 I left Cameroon in
search of better educational
opportunities at the time there was just
one University in Cameroon but Nigeria
next door offered some opportunities for
cameras of English instruction to be
trained in various fields so I moved
there but practicing my trade upon
traditions and colleges in Nigeria was
an even bigger challenge so I never the
consonant was offered a scholarship to
Boston University's my project for my
PhD
it is dis happening to see that with all
our challenges with all the talents with
all the skills we have in Africa as a
continent we tend to solve our problems
by parachuting in experts in the West
for short stays exporting the best and
brightest out of Africa and treating act
as a consonant in perpetual need of
handouts after my training at Boston
University I joined the research team at
the University of California's Institute
of the environmental sustainability
because of his reputation for
groundbreaking research and the
development of policies and programs
that save the lives of millions of
people the world over including
developer world and it has been shown
that for every skilled African that
returns home 9-year jobs are created in
the formal and informal sector so as
part of our program therefore to build a
sustainable Africa together we are
leading a more tighten Ischia to develop
the Congo Basin Institute in permanent
peace where Africans
can walk in partnership with
international researchers they're
walking are their own solutions to your
own problems
we are using our interdisciplinary
approach to show how universities NGOs
and private business can parent
International Development so instead of
parachuting in experts from the West for
short stays we are building a permanent
presence in Africa a one-stop shop for
logistics housing and development of
collaborative projects between Africans
and international researchers so this
has allowed students like Michelle to
receive high quality training in Africa
michelle is currently working in our
labs to investigate the effects of
climate change on insects West's PhD has
already secured his postdoctoral
fellowship that enabled him to stay on
the continent also through our local
health program dr. manga a butyl a young
Nigerian scientist can walk as a
postdoctoral fellow with the foundation
for professional development the
universe of Western Kip in southern
Africa under University of California at
the same time in this investigating the
effects of climate variability and
change on malaria transmission in Africa
indeed in manga is currently developing
models that will be used as an early
warning system to predict malaria
transmission in Africa so rather than
exporting our best and brightest Out of
Africa we are not touring and supporting
local talent in Africa for example like
me dr. Eric program was trained in the
US he returned home to Cameroon but
couldn't secure the necessary ins and he
found it incredibly challenging to
secure to practice at very low science
he knew he could so when I met Eric he
was at a verge of returning to the US
when we convinced him to suck
collaborate with the Congo Basin
Institute today his lab in Boyer has
over half dozen collaborative grants or
researchers from the US and Europe
supporting 14 graduate students nine of
them women are carrying out
groundbreaking research understanding
biodiversity and climate change human
health or attrition
so what are buying it ideas of Africa
taking handouts we are using our
interdisciplinary approach to empower
Africans to find their own solutions
right now we are working with local
communities and students a u.s.
entrepreneur scientists from the US and
Africa to find a way to sustainably grow
Abani the iconic African hardwood Abani
like most African hardwood exploit it
for timber but we know very little about
the ecology what disperses them how to
survive in our forests 80 to 200 years
this is Arvind a young PhD student
working in our labs conducting what is
turning out to be some cutting edge
tissue culture work
Irving is holding in her hands the first
ever new tree that was produced entirely
from tissues this is unique in Africa we
can now show that you can produce
African timber from different plant
tissues leaves stem suits in addition
from germinating them from seeds which
is very difficult task see so other
students will take the varieties of
ebony which are having a 10 device in
our lab craft them to produce saplings
and walk with local communities of coke
Robles evany with local food tree
species in their various farms using our
own three thumb approach Weber we invite
all the farmers to choose their own
trees visit the one in the farms so in
addition to the ebony the species which
the farmers choose themselves will be
produced using our modern techniques and
incorporated Indian language systems
such as the start benefiting from these
products while waiting for a ballot to
mature today we are planting 15,000
Eveleigh trees and camryn and for the
first time ever they won't be harvested
from the middle of the pristine forest
this is the model for Afghan hardwoods
and we are extending this to include sir
Kelly
Andrew bingra or a highly prized
hardwoods so if this examples existed
when I was 18
I'll never have left but because of
initiative lady Congo building Institute
I am coming back but I'm not coming back
alone
I am bringing with me Western scientists
and to pronounce and students the best
science from the best universities in
the world to walk and to live in Africa
but we all need to scale up this loca
powerful and empowerment approach so far
we have half a dozen universities and
angels as partners we are planning to
build a green facility that will expand
on our existing laboratory space and add
more housing and conference facilities
to promote long-term disciplinary
approach and we need to offer more
opportunities young Afghan scholars and
would scale it up by leveraging the
International Institute of Agriculture's
existing network of 17 research stations
across sub-saharan Africa the tables are
starting to turn and I hope they keep
turning to real several Afghan nations
like Cote d'Ivoire Tanzania and Senegal
among the top fastest growing economies
that can attract several opportunities
for private sector investment we want to
give more opportunities African scholars
and I long to see a day when the most
intelligent Africans will stay on this
continent and receive high quality
education through initiatives like the
Congo Basin Institute and when that
happens Africa will be on the way to
solving Africa's problems and in 50
years I hope someone will be giving a
TED talk on how to stop the brain drain
of Westerners leaving their homes to
walk and live in a pack
[Music]